this episode is brought to you by curiosity
stream a subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries
and non-fiction titles right now
you guys can get 25 off the cost of a
subscription more on them in just a bit
in the early 1860s the territory of colorado
would have been the perfect setting for a
classic western movie mexican farmers uneasily
cohabited with recently arrived american settlers
in gold prospectors the union cavalry and u.s
marshals patrolled the canyons woodlands and
gulchers searching for bandits skirmishing with
the native nations or recruiting volunteers for
the ongoing civil war in the east but from spring
to autumn 1863 these lawmen would be confronted
with a whole new breed of horror one we would
normally associate with another genre altogether
the territory settlers faced three seasons
of terror due to the murderous insanity
of the axemen of colorado felipe espinoza
described at the time as a mexican bandit
he achieved infamy as one of the first if
not the first serial killer of the wild west
nerio espinoza was born in 1827 in what is today
known as the el rito unincorporated community
in rio arriba county new mexico he was the older
of five siblings one of them his brother vervin
was born in 1831 and he'd become a trusted partner
in crime there's only sparse information about the
early lives of felipe and vivin and what we know
is that their parents were subsistence farmers of
legal means literacy was not a given amongst these
rural communities yet at least felipe and bivin
could read and write filippo was known amongst his
neighbors for his impulsive volatile and violent
temper this worsened after the mexican-american
war of 1846-1848 after the war the united states
acquired large swaths of territory from mexico
including the lands where the espinosas had
settled the territory of guadalupe dargo allowed
mexican residents to remain in the newly seeded
lands but washington also encouraged settlers
to travel west and start farming the same
territories inevitably simmering tension and open
conflict manifested between the two communities
known as hispanos and anglos as a proud hispano
felipe resented the anglo-newcomers he saw them
as usurpers oppressors and enemies of the true
catholic faith both espinosa brothers were indeed
devoutly religious and were members of the holy
brotherhood of the blood of our lord jesus christ
members of this paternity were also known as
penitents and provided philanthropic help to
the less fortunate however some of their number
also indulge in extreme religious practices such
as self-flagellation it's not clear if felipe
inflicted such violence upon himself but it
appears that he did inflict it upon others in
1854 the 27 year old espinosa decided he wanted
to marry but as he had no luck with the local
ladies he traveled south to the village of kachid
and abducted two sisters secondina and eugenia
aged 17 and 11 respectively thankfully he almost
immediately set free eugenia but he kept the older
sister with him for several days mentally and
physically abusing her secondina finally escaped
and returned to her family quickly chased by
felipe but her father terrified by espinosa's
violent character convinced the girl to marry
her abductor we don't know if their relationship
developed into less toxic patterns but we know
for sure that they went on to have three children
in 1858 the espinosa extended family moved from
el rito to the san luis valley southern colorado
the espinosas settled into a plaza or community of
small farm houses according to different sources
this plaza was either known as san rafael or san
judas and we're gonna go with judas by april 1861
the american civil war had erupted colorado was
not yet a state rather a territory and the ravages
of war had not yet reached the san luis valley
according to the census of the time felipe and
little brother vivin were making a living as
a brick maker and farmer respectively yet around
this time it appears that the two brothers took to
banditry it is unclear who was the bad influence
or exactly what were their crimes possibly
cattle rustling but it seems that they earned a
reputation in the press as desperate and lawless
for much of 1862 the espinosas were occasional
bandits amateurs if you like but their criminal
career was about to take a sharp turn in december
around that time a priest from the town of taos
purported a gruesome robbery to the u.s cavalry
stationed in fort garland two mars men had
held up a wagon carrying some of the priest's
properties the bandits looted the vehicle then
seized the driver juan gonzalez they tied the
poor man underneath the wagon and then whipped
the horses sending them galloping across the
rocky soil the drivers head and face hit every
bump and stone on the path turning it into a
bloody pulp luckily he survived and was able
to identify the culprits the espinosa brothers of
san judas plaza calvary lieutenant hart organized
an expedition in mid-january 1863 accompanied
by ten horsemen and u.s marshal george austin
the lawman paid two visits to felipe espinosa's
farmhouse the first time they pretended to be on
a recruitment mission most of the cavalrymen were
hispanos after all so why not enlist them and then
join the union army in the civil war they've been
talked to the lieutenant quite civilly apparently
it's not clear why hot did not arrest him and
felipe then and there instead the detachment
left and returned five days later this time
hodd and austin went straight for the arrest
locking felipe and vivin into their house but
then chaos broke loose apparently the espionages
had access to a veritable arsenal which nobody
had cared to confiscate the two brothers started
firing from the windows with pistols rifles and
even bows and arrows the cavalry shot back with
little success until hot ordered the house to be
set on fire at that point felipe and bibin made a
desperate sorde discharging more and more arrows
the lieutenant drew his pistol and fired all of
his rounds missing every single time his second
pistol didn't seem to work so he threw it to the
ground in frustration and that's when it decided
to work a bullet went off at that moment wounding
hot on the forehead in the meantime the espionages
were running away across the frozen river canals
marshall lost in gave chase but it all slipped
on the ice man and beast crashed to the ground
the whole expedition had been a disaster the two
bandit brothers had disappeared into the san juan
mountains the marshall had a broken leg the
lieutenant had almost shot himself in the
brain and sadly a corporal had been killed in the
hail of gunfire the army reacted harshly to the
debacle they completely burned down the espinosa's
farmhouse and confiscated all of their belongings
including their livestock the entire extended clan
was left destitute as a result the incident may
be at the root of the darkness that descended on
colorado the killing rage of the espinosa brothers
alright we'll get back to today's video in just
a moment first here's a word from today's sponsor
curiositystream curiositystream is
a subscription streaming service
that offers thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles from some of the world's
best filmmakers including exclusive originals
think of it as the netflix for nerds the
hulu for history buffs curiosity stream is
available on many platforms and web apps
including roku android xbox one smart tv's ios
chromecast amazon fire amazon kit on apple tv
it's also offered worldwide and with its
constantly updated content you'll always have
something to watch for example this spring
they added an eight-part series called the
bone detectives it's great stuff now if you like
biographies though and i've got to think you'd do
because you're maybe subscribed to this channel
you're at least watching it maybe head over to
curiositystream and check out bio documentaries
on alexander the great william conqueror and so
many more famous names and you could also check
out american icons in nine part series that tells
the story of babe ruth ellen and roosevelt mark
twain and more go to curiositystream.com for
unlimited access the world's top documentaries and
non-fiction series and right now you guys can use
the promo code biographics to save 25 off the cost
of an annual subscription which comes out to 14.99
not per month per year which is an incredible
deal so again curiositystream.com forward slash
biographics 25 off making it just 14.99 for
the whole year and now back to today's video
felipe and vivian stole two horses during their
retreat and made the mountains their new home
on the run from the law according to later
law it was during one of the freezing nights
camping in the woods that felipe had a vision a
revelation the virgin mary appeared in his dreams
send as a messenger from god the virgin
had ordered philippe to kill and kill again
until the blood of 600 anglos had been spilled
according to felipe's own later writings he had
lost six relatives during the mexican-american
war and he would wash that trespass in blood
of course by killing a hundred anglos for each
espinosa whatever the motivation the espinosas
were hell bent on going on a killing spree the
hunting ground initially was an area called
sawmill gulch just outside of canyon city it
later became known as dead man's gulch the first
victim was sawmill worker franklin bruce shot
on march 16 1863 according to some newspaper
reports a crucifix made of sticks protruded
from his bullet wound two days later it was
lumberjack henry harkins's turn his co-workers
found him one evening laying inside his cabin
he had been shot in the forehead with the cult
navy revolver he also had two stab wounds on
his chest the most gruesome detail is that the
murderer had split his head in half with an axe
and they had inflicted further blows to his skull
scattering fragments of bone and brain matter on
the floor in a matter of days the third victim was
found james adam and killed near wilkerson pass
west of colorado springs during april the bloody
espinosas targeted the town of fair play jacob
binkley and abraham shoop were taken by surprise
as they camped outside the city limits binkley was
shot in the back and died on the spot the shop
was stabbed three times and tried to escape but
collapsed after a short run three more men were
slain by the end of the month one had been shot
another one's head was crushed under a rock
a third one had died with a bloody crucifix
carved onto his chest at the time lorman had not
connected these deaths with the two bandits from
san judas they believed the culprit to be a lone
wolf dubbed by the press the axeman of colorado
the dwellers of the territory were gripped by fear
and suspicion any stranger wandering into town
could be the dreaded killer an unlucky prospector
mr foster arrived in the town of alma at the wrong
time he was suspected of being the axe man and
beset by the gelanti mob the townsfolk dragged
him to a tree for hanging he was saved at the
last minute by the oratory prowess of a minister
who subdued the crowd the governor of the
territory john evans offered a bounty for the
capture of the axeman he also appointed colonel
john chivington to lead an infantry detachment
to search the region one of the officers involved
was lieutenant schoop brother of one of the fair
play victims he offered to double the bounty
out of his own pocket but the axe man or
we should say axe men remained elusive it was
later rumored that they were helped by other
brothers of the penitentiary fraternity but it is
more realistic that they simply moved very quickly
along mountain paths preying on lone travelers as
they added more victims to their tally the spree
killers refined their modus operandi in the second
phase of their descent into madness they ditched
the cult for long-range rifles after stalking
their prey they cut them down from afar then they
descended upon the corpses like vultures and
set to work bodies were found disemboweled
decapitated and with their hearts brutally
removed or impaled by wooden stakes however
ghoulish the two murderers were all too human
and sooner or later they would commit a mistake
a lumberjack called massie metcalfe was
driving a wagon down california gulch when
the espinosa suddenly appeared in front of
him without saying a word one of them fired
a shot hitting metcalf on the left breast the
lumberman fell backwards into the wagon as the
panicked horses dashed wildly away felipe espinoza
later wrote in his diary killed a man in a wagon
but he hadn't matthew had been saved by a booklet
of lincoln's emancipation proclamation stuffed
into his breast pocket the pages had slowed down
the flight of the bullet saving mikkoff's life
finally there was a survivor someone who could
help describe and locate the scourges of colorado
metcalfe reported the botched shooting and a
posse of eight men was quickly formed in fair play
led by john mccannon the posse found a promising
trail of hoofprints close to california gulch
following the path the horsemen found a gruesome
clue a corpse butchered beyond recognition well
almost one member of the posse recognized the body
because it belonged to his brother mccannon and
his men continued riding for one day and one night
after daybreak they saw two horses calmly grazing
behind a screen of campfire smoke the potty split
into two groups and approached the campsite they
crept through the grass fingers nervously
twitching by the trigger of their guns when
a human figure emerged from a bush the men of fair
play reacted quickly too quickly perhaps without
any warning a shot rang out a red stain bloomed
on the man's side as he slumped to the ground it
could have been any innocent traveler but in this
case it wasn't vivin espinoza cried out in fury
and returned fire with his cult more rounds came
flying in his direction until one tore through
his brain a second figure came running from behind
the trees mccannon shouted to hold fire believing
him to be a member of his posse this was felipe of
course taking advantage of the moment of confusion
he sprinted away before the fair play gunman
could take aim espinoza disappeared into the
woods pursued by those who had killed his brother
he managed to evade capture until sundown when
the posse returned to the encampment the nail lone
axemen followed them stealthily and shot one last
time before disappearing for good the bullet
missed the man who had killed bobin by a mere
three inches mccannon and his men returned to
fairplay with a valuable load all the loot that
the espionage had stolen from their victims and
felipe's own diary based on the property seized
fair play authorities concluded that the outlaws
have killed at least 12 men but in philippi's
diary they found an unsent letter to the colorado
governor in which he confessed to 32 victims
with vivinded and felipe once more on the run
colorado breathed a sigh of relief the summer
was relatively calm no more anglos were felled
by the axe the army and posses of settlers still
roamed the woods and mountains but felipe managed
to elude them even returned several times to his
family's dwelling san judas plaza when visiting
he dropped further letters and portions of his
diaries confessing to the string of murders
and threatening further violence he also took
notice of his family's condition following the
cavalry raid in january the espionage had fallen
into abject poverty it was during one of these
visits that felipe recruited a new accomplice a
nephew of which little is known he may have been
14 and his name may have been julio it's not even
clear why he recruited the boy was he looking
to initiate a new generation of espionages to
anti-anglo-violence or maybe he just needed
somebody to look after the horses and the campfire
whatever julio's age or function felipe returned
to his murderous ways in autumn 1863 as the leaves
started to fall so too did the bodies in a matter
of a few weeks at least 11 killings were recorded
in southern and central colorado attributed to
espinosa on the 11th of october 1863 felipe and
julio had set up an ambush at levator pass as a
wagon approached philippe attacked guns in hand
the wagon occupants a man and a woman fled on foot
in opposite directions the espinosas ran after the
man called philbrook but soon lost track of him on
the mountainside they returned to levator looking
for the woman dolores sanchez meanwhile she had
hidden aboard another wagon driven by two hispanos
felipe and julio held up that wagon as well
and upon finding that the drivers were mexican
they seemed eager to let them go unharmed
dolores could have made it unscathed too
had she not emerged from our hiding place pleading
for the driver's lives her generosity of spirit
would not be rewarded alas felipe allowed the
two drivers to trot away but would not reserve
the same favor for the lady with julio's help
felipe bound her tightly and then proceeded
to rape her the espionages abandoned her on the
mountainside as they galloped towards more mayhem
but help was on its way pillbrook had reached
fort garland and alerted its commander colonel
tap into the situation tappan dispatched
a patrol who found laura in bad shape
but still alive back at the fort dolores
and philbrook were able to give a detailed
description of felipe tappan was ready to
strike back but he would not lead the expedition
he knew just the right man who could locate
the espionages and deal the final blow
that man was named thomas tate tobin a well-known
tracker trapper and us army scout who had fought
alongside while bill hicker and kit carson in the
wars against the native americans tappan summoned
tobin to the fort where he had the opportunity
to further question philbrook and dolores
with all the info he needed the scout reared
to start the hunt immediately alone only upon
tappan's insistence did he accept an escort of 15
cavalrymen with his uncanny tracking skills tobin
followed the trail of the espinosas for three
days and three nights every broken stick every
bent blade of grass on the ground spoke to tobin
telling him where the bandits were headed on the
morning of the fourth date the scout saw magpies
flying in circles in the distance an indication of
human presence this was confirmed by a thin column
of smoke lazily rising above the treetops tobin
ordered the soldiers to stay put loaded his rifle
dropped to his stomach and crawled toward the
campsite two men sat by the fire with a dead ox
beside them the tracker recognized them from the
description he had heard at the fort it was the
espinosas a snapping sound reverberated through
the forest maybe a breaking branch it was enough
to start a felipe who reached for his rifle tobin
reacted on instinct barely taking aim he released
a slug hitting felipe on the chest the killer fell
backward onto the campfire calling for julio
to run away the young nephew sped through the
woods a swift shadow appearing and disappearing
amongst the trees now tobin took time to perfectly
adjust his aim he squeezed the trigger a second
time and julio's spine was shattered by hot lad
but felipe was still alive he crawled across the
forest floor and braced himself against a tree he
lifted his rifle and shot against tobin but missed
the union cavalrymen now intervened releasing a
devastating volley felipe espinoza the axeman
sent by the virgin to slay the anglos withered
and jerked against the tree bark as bullet after
bullet drained every drop of life from his body
but when he fell to the ground apparently he still
had one ounce of life left inside him tobin walked
slowly to him and lifted him by the hair as
he pulled out his bowie knife tobin asked him
do you know who i am with his last breath felipe
muttered bruto a brute then the brute's blade fell
twice upon the neck of espionosa days later tobin
returned to fort garland as he strode into the
office of colonel tap and he announced got them
tap and asked got what tobin opened the flower
sack he'd been carrying and pulled out the heads
of felipe and julio and thus ends the narrative of
felipe vivin and julio the bloodiest banosas
who may have been the first documented serial
killers in the history of the wild west events
grew to acquire legendary status perpetuated by
one macabre relic felipe's head preserved in a
jar of alcohol was exhibited as a traveling act
before ending up on the desk of a newspaper
editor then the head disappeared as the memory
of the espinosas faded from history according
to author adam jones a preserved head which
may have been his was found in the early 2010s
in the basement of colorado's capitol building
it was incinerated before it could be analyzed to
this day many details concerning the espionage's
killings and their eventual demise are still
disputed even the motivations behind their
spree are not entirely clear was felipe
driven to kill by delirious dreams and
visions of the virgin mary or was the violence
political in nature a revengeful rampage against
the anglo-oppressor maybe he was just a
vile psychopath who had strung along his
younger brother and teenage nephew or was he
an insurgent fighting with the wrong methods
against depression perhaps felipe's rage was
fueled by all of these elements and the raid
on his plaza was just the last straw that had
tipped him over the edge into darkness so i
hope you enjoyed today's episode just before you
leave today a quick plug for one of my other shows
the casual criminalist it's a true crime show
where we dive into the stories of some of the
worst of the worst murderers serial killers cult
leaders we cover it all but it's also pretty laid
back doesn't take itself too seriously and it
could even be called a bit fun it's the casual
criminalist there's a link below also available
as a podcast by the way and thank you for watching
you